go forward can you hear it change is
coming that hasn't happened years and we
are driving that change together but
because
Asian guys speaking Russian that's crazy
that's the translator that's uh that
she's telling a poo in this but his
translators
at it or is it the No No the the the
Russian the Asian guy is that she's
translator he's translating in Russian
to tweet smart to find out who's saying
this at this point yeah it sort of is
important very important yeah she says
that she's seeing it yeah yeah
that's she that she's a translator which
which threw me off because I'm like yo
that guy's by the way I mean look can we
watch Putin wave goodbye like a 16 year
old girl
please watch this let me see
bye it does it four more times bye I
love you watch this and even as you
drove off jog down the street yeah it
very clearly shows who's the boss in
that I mean but that's pretty cheap
that's pretty scary little Sam like like
to see these two guys two of our biggest
like adversaries coming together and
doing like a hey like it's gonna be good
from now on it's kind of a scary that's
a scary ass moment if you ask me I mean
I I am really
um uh I I
I I am really reluctant to
um to get too like engaged in wanting to
have a conflict with China I mean this
has been coming for a couple of decades
back when I was doing uh radio I
interviewed Gary Hart Who Sat on a uh a
commission right before 9 11 on the
greatest threats to the United States in
the 21st century and they had a
commission of about I don't know like 30
40 people had them lined up what do you
think is the number one threat to uh the
United States most of the people said
non-state actor terrorists that was
pretty prescient some said State uh
State supported terrorists one person
said China this is in 1999 or 2000 and
um
three months later they meet again same
thing happens everybody laughs at the
person in China that person never came
back onto the commission wow it was Dick
Cheney's wife and I'm quite convinced
that for a long time the uh
neoconservatives you know uh primarily
in the Republican party but some I think
in you know the Democratic party but
primarily in the Republican Party have
been you know worried about China uh and
it's all about economic dominance
um and I think that like
uh you know we had the Asian uh pivot if
you remember back into what you probably
were aware of this in uh in the in the
Arts where our fleet was moved to the
Pacific from the Atlantic
um and we've been gearing up for this
conflict with China basically to protect
the interests of uh multinational
corporations particularly American
corporations and that's what the TPP was
all about
um and I you know I'm in favor of making
sure that we have uh supply lines and
Logistics you know moving and having
production uh you know uh on short but I
also like think that like we should not
be getting into a war to protect the
interests of some corporation who's you
know who's not necessarily providing
benefit to the United States per se how
how do you how do you see this in in
regards to uh Ukraine and how this
affects Ukraine does this show you know
hey uh uh Ukraine U.S all the proxy
awards that you're causing look who's
teaming up with me now XI is this going
to change the strategy of U.S and NATO
towards Ukraine or this doesn't do
anything there
um I I don't I don't know
could change anything in the context of
Ukraine I mean I I
I I
would I understand why we we we we
probably wouldn't hear of what the exit
strategy is but I think that we should
have some type of exit strategy in terms
of support for Ukraine I agree at the
same time
um this is not a a fight that the United
States picked I I am someone who who
felt like we shouldn't expand NATO
um in fact I think I was somebody who
was feeling like we can start to sort of
maybe disengage on some level NATO that
is now obviously off the table because
you know
Putin if if he was worried about NATO it
was the worst thing he could have
possibly done it seems to me uh was to
give everybody in Europe a reason to be
supportive of of NATO but
um look we made a deal with Ukraine in
93 give up your uh your your nukes and
we will protect you and
uh i i i as long as we don't have regime
change uh and as long as like we uh
there's you know some like sort of
clear-eyed notion of like how much
um uh territory Ukraine can get back I
don't know that we're gonna go to
pre-2014 borders
um but at the same time also you can't
you know I wouldn't want the look I was
against the Iraq War
I'm against uh uh Russia's invasion of
Ukraine same same arguments like I'm not
I'm not convinced that there was a
imminent threat to Russia from Ukraine
uh that that brought about their uh
their attacks on on are you in favor of
the amount of support we're given
Ukraine right now
you know I'm of two minds of it I mean
you know I think like obviously we need
to provide them uh some support but I I
do worry about how deep our engagement
gets I I think that like if you're Putin
you're waiting to see if Donald Trump
becomes president
because
um if Donald Trump becomes president
then you're quite confident that all the
funding is going to dry up and you stay
into that war
The Dilemma that the bide Administration
has they have to show like overwhelming
commitment that would like surpass that
would go beyond uh even if Donald Trump
becomes president
um and and so why do things some may say
uh if if Putin is waiting for Trump to
become president because the funding
would dry up for Ukraine to get weaker
why didn't he attack Ukraine under Trump
because he would have never supported
you he thought that he could get Ukraine
without having to be military and go in
militarily do you think I think he
thought that Trump was going to deliver
him Ukraine I'm not convinced that I
mean you had manaforton didn't you or
something like that yeah we did yeah
yeah we did have it he would have been a
good guy to ask why uh yeah why Putin a
very interesting guy to have on oh yeah
I would imagine he's very smart but uh
but from all that that's going on from
all that that hooking up with you know
she and poo and just was it yesterday
right after this meeting or was it
before was threatening he's like if the
if the West sends tanks or any depleted
uranium or anything to to help uh
Ukraine fight that war he's like nuclear
components and attack well like now this
guy's threatening like he threatened
that you know early on too I mean the
problem with backing down from a nuclear
threat is that becomes all of a sudden
like licensed to do whatever you want if
you have nukes I mean
um it's it's a dilemma I don't think the
by Administration wanted this by any
stretch of the imagination I in fact the
report no did not I think the reporting
actually was that the Biden
Administration was convinced that Putin
would take over Ukraine within a matter
of days and with a week and then the
problem that or the Dilemma they had or
you know for many in the in National
Security State I think they saw it as an
opportunity was that Putin was not doing
well yeah and that Russia was a bit of a
paper tiger and then at that point it
gave it opened the door of an
opportunity for all these warhawks and
these people who want to make a ton of
money by selling and Manufacturing
weapons you know what I wonder I wonder
I'm sorry let me just say this I wonder
if you know how you feel about Iraq not
just you a lot of people on both sides
feel about Iraq and how it was a waste
of a war and then the way we got out of
it and it cost us another 83 billion
dollars we can go and talk from many
different angles I wonder
what people will say about our our level
of support to Ukraine 10 20 years from
now I am so curious I'm so curious if
it's going to be another one of those we
should have never gone in or it's going
to be we should have gone in more or if
Trump was President this would have
never happened or the motives the
intentions the reasoning uh I don't
think a hundred percent we're gonna know
what's really going on there for a
minute yeah and I think we can and we'll
never know what would have happened had
we not provided Ukraine with the ability
to stop uh Russia from making it part of
a Russian Empire and where would would
um Putin's
um uh interest end at Ukraine certainly
there's there's countries around there
that don't feel that way well revisiting
your comment about
uh how much support Biden has given and
why he's doubling down and sending
yelling and sending uh Lincoln and
selling all the latest was Merrick
Garland he just he's doubling down on
this why do you think that is well I
think I think if I'm Putin I'm thinking
that you know I'm gonna wait I'm gonna
wait because if the administration
changes it's it's a change right like
you know if you don't like uh your
situation that's an old edict right if
you don't like your situation you wait
and see uh you know there's going to be
a change coming or possibly and this is
Biden trying to sort of like signify
that we're not going to do that there
was reporting about back moot where the
the bite administration had told uh
Ukraine
you've got to cut your losses in back
moot because it's just not strategically
necessary and you don't have the ability
to do it you don't have the ability to
take over Crimea you don't have the
ability to do this you just don't our
our analysts think that you don't have
the ability to do it and uh but then you
know uh it it was almost like that got
too much publicity and the Biden
Administration can't show that level of
weakness they need to show full
commitment so that Putin thinks they're
in for the Long Haul I don't know this
is like these games are horrible so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you
foreign